hello my name is Aneesh Lima Azevedo I'm
a research assistant
in the Department of engineering and
public policy and I'm also the co PI and
the executive director for the climate
and energy decision-making Center this
is a large center anchored at Carnegie
Mellon but distributed across several
universities and funded by NSF today
I'll be talking about the prospects for
energy efficiency in the United States
so if we start with the premise that we
need to reduce substantially the amount
of greenhouse gas emissions by roughly
an order of magnitude we'll need to
start rethinking the way we produce use
and transform energy in the United
States well if it is that the if that is
the case then we need to start series of
thinking where we start so what this
float diagram shows is the amount of co2
emissions in the US economy by sector
buy and use and so what you can see in
the first instance is that most of the
co2 are related to energy but also that
there is a substantial part of co2
emissions that are related to
residential buildings and commercial
buildings so there is an opportunity to
with new technologies reduce the
emissions perhaps in a cost-effective
like cost-effectively way so us is doing
already quite a bit in terms of energy
efficiency policies so currently in the
United States energy efficiency is in
fact perceived by many as one of the key
climate change strategies and energy
efficiency resource standards are
already in the underway in several
states what our energy efficiency
resource standards well it is a mandated
goal to reduce energy consumption by a
certain amount and by a certain date as
you can see in the map several states
have those goals sometimes those are
mandated goals in other cases not some
include both electricity and natural gas
others include only electricity there
are also quite large investments in
energy efficiency that are done at
different levels both federal and state
for example the spending by electric
utilities in the United States is
roughly four point five billion dollars
per year at the same time with the
American Recovery and Reinvestment Act
of 2009
a substantial portion of money was
allocated for energy efficiency programs
eleven billion dollars and Pennsylvania
for example was awarded point five
billion dollars so how much are we
getting out of those investments well
that's what millions are all of my
colleagues have spent a substantial
amount of time trying to define how much
you - can we actually reduce by pursuing
energy efficiency strategies so we've
done so by creating a model that looks
at the different residential energy
induces in the different regions of the
United States and tries to determine
four different policy goals whether it
is to reduce co2 emissions reduce
electricity consumption or primary or
final energy what is the best allocation
of technologies that should be pursued
so what you see in the fear is on the
y-axis the cost of effectiveness of
different interventions and on x-axis
the amount of co2 emissions that can be
avoided through those interventions so
every little point in that curve
corresponds to for example switching
from incandescent to fluorescent lamps
in the northeastern region so now the
green area that is below zero
corresponds to actually things that will
save money to consumers and that are
cost effective the red area corresponds
to things where consumers would need to
spend money to reduce co2 emissions so
in an in a nutshell what we found is
that we could achieve 30% of emissions
reductions in the residential sector in
the United States in a way that would
actually save money to consumers now
there are several factors some related
to markets some related to behavior that
prevents this potential from being
achieved so what are those factors what
is their importance in terms of choices
and behavior to move to move towards a
more sustainable energy system well
that's what we've been working on - so
in several studies looking how at how
people choose and use technologies have
been able to detect and identify what
are those key factors namely price and
the disconnect between between the way
people perceive technological attributes
and those
actual technological attributes we've
been doing several studies for that in
the case of lighting exposing folks to
different lighting conditions with
different brightness different color and
trying to identify what are the
technologies that are preferred and the
conditions that are preferred by
consumers I'm not going to present the
results from that work today but from a
related work which is the following if
people invest in energy efficiency and
energy efficient devices then if those
are cost effective they will save money
over the lifetime of of that investment
think about the case of switching from
incandescent lamps to fluorescent lamps
you're saving money over the lifetime of
the technology then the question arises
what do you do with those savings well
if what you do with those savings is
leaving the lights on for longer periods
of time that's called the direct rebound
effect if what you do is basically you
take the money that you saved with that
investment and spend it to travel abroad
that's called the indirect rebound
effect so in work with one of my PhD
students bring the thomas and with
colleagues from Carnegie Mellon we're
trying to understand what's the
magnitude of that effect
there is a huge uncertainty whether
those rebound effects actually matter or
not some argue that those effects are so
small that they can be neglected others
argue that they are so large that they
can actually backfire this means that
energy consumption and co2 emissions
could actually increase as a result of
energy efficiency policies rather than
decrease so we've looked at the case of
energy efficiency in juices in the
residential sector that are powered
either by electricity natural gas or
gasoline and try to understand what the
estimates for those effects would be so
we start by using a model that was
developed here at Carnegie Mellon to
assess what would be the supply chain
effects in terms of carbon footprints of
US households here I show the results
for an average u.s. household and
basically showing in each one of those
stacks not only the site emissions from
the household activities
to the indirect ones so the gasoline
emissions are not only the emissions
from driving but also to build your car
and etc so the scenario that we're
trying to look at is when you pursue an
energy efficiency strategy that reduces
gasoline consumption as it is shown in
the figure how much of that is going to
be used to drive more and how much of
this is going to be allocated to other
end users so by using income and price
elasticities and the series of different
scenarios for different income levels
what we found is that in fact there is
no evidence of backfire so the emissions
are always reduced and the energy
consumption is always reduced after
those interventions it is also the case
that the rebound effects both the direct
and indirect are not overwhelming they
are always less than 30%
however they are large enough that they
should be considered in policy analysis
and in projections of future energy
demand so in with this whole end thank
you so much for your attention